[Musique]
et
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo l'émission
de la rédaction pour revenir sur
l'actualité départementale de la semaine
voici les titres de ce vendredi 6
octobre 500 entreprises présentes 700
participants le monde de l'économie
avaient rendez vous jeudi au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
pour la deuxième édition du scania
business des retours sur l'événement en
début d'émission karl olive est notre
invité fil rouge pour cette émission le
maire de poissy vient de lancer une
nouvelle association génération terrain
un mouvement qui se veut transparent et
qui vise à rassembler les bonnes
pratiques sans pression des partis
politiques traditionnels enfin dans le
reste de l'actualité retour sur le
déplacement de la ministre des
transports à versailles ou une
expérience de tri alimentaire qui a lieu
en ce moment dans une école élémentaire
à magny-les-hameaux entrepreneurs et
décideurs politiques étaient donc réunis
ce jeudi au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'enceinte
accueillait la deuxième édition du sky
business des pour favoriser les échanges
et les rencontres entre les acteurs
économiques locaux les détails avec
aurélie rose et patrick jacques de
dixmude des tables des rendez vous en
tête à tête mais ne vous y trompez pas
il ne s'agit pas d'un speed dating
amoureux mais de rencontres
professionnelles c'est le concept du sky
business day pour la deuxième année
consécutive cette convention d'affaires
réunis grands groupes pme et tpe
en tout 600 entreprises ont investi le
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
tout le monde parle d'emploi d'emploi
mais
il y aura plus d'emplois si vous
augmentez l'activité économique de nos
entreprises donc c'est ce que l'on fait
en démultipliant leurs prospects donc
leurs clients vous augmenter leur
activité économique et donc bien sûr
l'emploi c'est deux entreprises basées
sur notre territoire ne se connaissaient
pas l'une est spécialisée en prises de
vue aériennes la deuxième propose des
loisirs connectés dans les milieux
aquatiques 25 minutes plus tard
l'entretien s'est révélé fructueux
dès le début d'année est ce
effectivement se revoir pour le préciser
effectivement quel type d'événement va
pouvoir prévoir à mettre en place pour
le printemps été 2010 huit nouveautés de
cette édition 2010 est le village de
l'innovation 10 start up implantée à
saint quentin en yvelines ont été
sélectionnés pour mettre en avant leurs
innovations parmi elles taken by un
service de commande et de livraison qui
verra prochainement le jour et qui a pu
multiplier les contacts lors de
l'événement qu'on a rencontré la banque
populaire on a parlé des financements
c'est très important pour une start up
il ya un effet de levier qui est
important pour nous pour qu'on puisse
développer notre notre solution et le
groupe hôtelier entre aux cotonniers
justement on aimerait connaître leurs
besoins en matière de livraison les
entreprises de saint quentin en yvelines
vont d'ailleurs pouvoir mieux se
connaître grâce à la sky business map
présentés lors de l'événement un outil
interactif qui permet de découvrir
l'ensemble de l'écosystème territoriale
et vous l'avez vu dans ce sujet jean
michel fourgous le maire d'elancourt et
vice président de saint quentin en
yvelines étaient présents pour ce rendez
vous nous avons profité de l'occasion
pour évoquer avec lui la succession de
michel laugier fraîchement élue au sénat
à la tête de l'agglomération jean michel
fourgous a remporté cette semaine une
élection interne à la droite et sera
ainsi le candidat de la majorité
il a donc de fortes chances de devenir
le nouveau président de saint quentin en
yvelines ont les couteaux mais crée au
micro d'aurélie rose ça se présente bien
bouger beaucoup de mes collègues élus
voilà qui qui qui jouent le jeu en plus
eux qui m'ont dit qu'ils vont y voyez
pas ce que c'est normal il y avait
plusieurs tendances mai
qui veut tron normalement puisque on est
quand même majoritaire de tout ça sent
bon bien sûr mais non je suis chaud
petit mist
brouillard deux ou trois c'est la vie
démocratique cgt dit avant de mettre 500
sony ses débuts c'est celui que j'ai
vécu ça mais globalement il ya une vraie
tendance
et ce chamboulement à la tête de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines est la conséquence directe des
élections sénatoriales des élections qui
ont profité largement aux républicains
dans les yvelines avec cinq postes raflé
sur six on va parler de ce sujet avec
notre invité fil rouge karl olive
bonsoir bonsoir nicolas karl olive vous
êtes maire de poissy vice président du
conseil départemental également vous
avez conquis ses mandats à l'époque avec
l'étiquette ump est ce que vous avez
encore l'étiquette lr aujourd'hui
puisqu'il ya des informations qui
courent comme quoi vous pourriez
potentiellement quitté le parti est ce
que c'est le cas alors j'ai
effectivement été élu sous l'étiquette
ump puis les républicains en 2014 et en
aujourd'hui je suis toujours sous
l'étiquette lrg pas renouveler mon mon
adhésion on va y revenir je me sens
profondément d'abord un élu de terrain
sous j'irai couvert d'une droite sociale
humaniste et moderne vous attendez les
élections de la présidence on a 2
décembre pour savoir si vous renouveler
ou pas en gros si wauquiez remporté
l'élection alors geste envers le livre
pourrait quitter le jeu jonathan
strictement rien parce que je ne mène
pas une politique de terrain en fonction
des étiquettes
évidemment j'aime à dire que le matin
quand je me lève je me lève pas en
disant je vais faire une politique ni de
gauche ni de droite mais plutôt une
politique juste et équilibrée donc mais
moi ce que j'adore aussi pour les pour
les parties généralement proches mac
saison de la fibre de droite je bouge
crois que c'est de moins en moins le cas
c'est moi c'est mieux qu'un 5e sélection
le séisme des présidentielles a montré
que aujourd'hui il fallait peut-être
passer à autre chose et c'est un petit
peu le sens de la démarche que je mène
avec avec mon ami arnaud péricard le
maire de saint germain en laye on va en
parler de génération terrain c'est le
mouvement que vous avez lancée mais
encore un mot sur l air dans le 78 alors
on va dire globalement que le parti se
trouve dans une situation paradoxale
élections législatives catastrophiques
un poste sur dix seulement sénatoriales
plutôt bonne
cinq postes sur 6 mais on ne sait pas
trop ce qui se passe on ne voit plus le
président du parti david douillet qu'en
est il de l air dans les yvelines où
d'abord je pense qu'il faut d'abord
féliciter la formidable campagne de
terrain de gérard larcher le président
sortant et donc nouveau président du
sénat
262 visite sur les 262 communes du
département
il n'y a pas de secret y'a pas de
surprise quand vous êtes ancré sur le
terrain quand vous êtes convaincus de ce
que vous faites forcément vous êtes
convaincant et aujourd'hui cinq
candidats au sénat son étiquette et
l'air autour de gérard larcher ont été
élus sur six c'est le fruit d'un travail
juste exceptionnel moi j'aime à dire que
le travail en train le talent le talent
entraîne la chance et la réussite là il
ya d'abord eu du travail et il ya
toujours du talent chez jura large qui
veut dire potentiellement que par
exemple david douillet ne ne travaille
pas assez n'est pas assez sur le terrain
pour l'air dans les abîmes on va pas non
plus comparer comparer des séquences
électorale où on s'aperçoit que la
législative a été d'abord une élection
très nationale avec la continuité de ce
que souhaitaient les français c'est à
dire de donner le crédit et la chance
entre guillemets au président macron
ensuite on a un retour des choses qui
montrent que lorsque vous êtes candidat
au sénat
il faut savoir de quoi on parle il y
avait douze listes il ya cette liste
emmenée par gérard larcher qui est
arrivée largement devant et tant mieux
c'est un gage aussi de deux d'assurance
aussi pour les élus de terrain que nous
sommes parce que la raie manta le
travail paie déjà
et la réalité c'est celle du terrain
c'est pas celle des bureaux on y
reviendra
c'est pas celle du sommet de l'état
c'est celle du terrain et moi ce que
j'aimerais c'est qu'effectivement les
élus de terrain de gauche comme de
droite soit un tout petit peu plus
entendus et écoutés
plutôt que de nous imposer des choses
qu'ils ne prouvaient la personne alors
le terrain c'est l'objet principal du
mouvement de l'association vous avez
lancé génération terrain avec le maire
de saint germain en laye arnaud péricard
c'était fin septembre le lancement
officiel
question simple et peut être naïve mais
essentielle à quoi ça sert concrètement
cette association
arnaud péricard pauline vino pour
lefebvre qui est vice présidente lui
aussi du département des yvelines
et puis élu à montfort l'amaury à quoi
ça sert c'est simplement un laboratoire
de bonnes pratiques et puis un échange
aussi de bonnes idées qui se passe sur
le terrain
on est dans la droite ligne de ce qu'on
a monté avec arnaud et olivier de la
faire le club des loges qui était en
quelque sorte un club de réflexion avec
des élus dé nos élus là on souhaite
aller plus loin pour créer ce mouvement
humanisme moderne ouvert de droite pas
forcément pas forcément de droite bat
j'irais plutôt d'une philosophie de
droite sociale humaniste tel que nous le
sommes avec harvey carnot péricard et et
pauline mais d'abord de son côté
pragmatique on a des échanges de bonnes
idées qui fonctionne dans nos communes
et nous si ça fonctionne dans nos
communes il n'y a pas de raison que ça
fonctionne pas à l'échelle d'un
territoire et peut être un peu plus loin
aujourd'hui on a à peu près 100 et cette
semaine on a un collègue élu dans le
gers qui nous a rejoints on a un conseil
départemental du finistère qui nous a
rejoint
on voit bien que nous sommes dans le
vrai mais ça dans le vrai pardon de le
dire
les élus de terrain les collègues mais
encore une fois de gauche comme de
droite
le sont dans le vrai la seule difficulté
c'est pour ça qu'on essaie de faire
bouger les lignes
c'est qu'on n'est pas entendue on n'est
pas écoutés pardonnez-moi nicolas de
poursuivre les employés des faits sans
aucune concertation
on sait que c'est un camp un pansement
sur une jambe de bois là là on évoque
des sujets politiques
est ce que ça veut dire que génération
terrain à vocation à devenir un moment
un mouvement politique si la mayonnaise
prend si c'est une affaire qui roule qui
marche qui qui permet d'englober
beaucoup de personnes est ce que vous
aspirez devenir un mouvement politique
n'est pas un mouvement politique
en revanche fondé une association et on
sait que cette association va peser sur
le territoire c'est d'ores et déjà le
cas on sera évidemment présent dans
toutes les dents toutes les séquences
mais il n'y a pas de difficulté à être
complémentaires
d'autres structures je prends le cadre
du département des yvelines pierre
bédier a créé un groupe qui s'appelle
ensemble pour les yvelines qui
fonctionne très bien avec différentes
sensibilités
on est capable d'être complémentaire
effectivement de cela tout ça c'est pour
dire que en fait les partis
traditionnels les étiquettes
traditionnel type lr ça ne marche plus
les gens ça ne s'accroche plus avec avec
le citoyen avec le lecteur écoutez on
peut quand même constater tout
simplement constaté un que la séquence
présidentielle a été catastrophique pour
la droite comme pour la gauche il s'est
quand même passé quelque chose
aujourd'hui est ce qu on entend beaucoup
parler la crédibilité des républicains
est ce qu on entend beaucoup parler
la crédibilité des élus socialistes
n'ont faut dire les choses non et
pourtant il ya des personnalités très
très efficace dansez dansez deux
obédiences entre guillemets mais nous ce
qu'on souhaite c'est qu'effectivement on
dépasse les clivages pour être dans un
sens je dirais pragmatique par rapport à
ce qui se fait alain juppé à bordeaux le
tramway c'est exceptionnel françois
rebsamen sénateur de gauche à dijon le
tramway c'est exceptionnel mais voilà
ces deux de ces exemples-là inspiré des
il ya des élus de la république en
marche qui sont déjà aux deux
générations et voilà je pense que on va
pas se mentir génération terrain ça
ressemble un peu au mouvement lancé il
ya plus d'un an maintenant par emmanuel
macron en marche
moi je dirais que si vous parlez de cela
je vous renvoie aussi au club des loges
qu'on a lancé il ya six ans maintenant
avec moi je sais pas si emmanuel macron
s'est inspiré en tout cas ce que je sais
c'est que pour le coup emmanuel macron a
d'abord passé beaucoup de temps sur le
terrain avant de je dirais de de maillé
ce qu'il a pu proposer avec
effectivement un alignement des planètes
qui se reproduira peut-être pas dit si
d'ici une dizaine ou une vingtaine
d'années nous simplement humblement
modestement on a des idées on met en
place des choses dans nos dans nos
collectivités 2002 puis 2014 qui
fonctionne très bien et on s'aperçoit
aujourd'hui que ces échanges de bonnes
pratiques peuvent faire en sorte d'être
dans un meilleur vivre ensemble où les
différentes sensibilités viennent
simplement se compléter au service de
l'intérêt général et d'une richesse
voilà c'est ça qui nous intéresse
concrètement comment ça va se passer sur
le terrain vous allez faire des réunions
publiques aller vers les gens où il
restera confiné entre eux et entre élus
alors c'est un mouvement qui est d'abord
dirigés vers les élus pour les élus avec
les élus évidemment mais on va prendre
des exemples qui encore une fois se
passe bien je vous en donne un appeau si
on a instauré une taxe qui s'appelle
l'effet sur les friches commerciales
ou quand à un propriétaire de beaux donc
de commerce n'est pas n'a pas son
commerce qui est ouvert depuis deux ans
il est taxé à 20% 30% 40% les trois
années suivantes
mais ça fonctionne puisque saint quentin
en yvelines a mis la même taxe en
application depuis quelques temps
exactement et on s'aperçoit que sur
quinze commerces y en a huit qui sont
ouverts qui ont rouvert qui était pas
ouvert depuis de plusieurs années et en
plus la ville a récupéré quarante deux
mille euros
voilà des petites choses des petits
exemples qui fonctionne et je sais que
les collègues de génération terrain vont
pouvoir sont inspirés la même manière
que les biarrots péricard actuellement à
saint germain en laye elle est en train
d'expérimenter une nouvelle forme de
société d'économie mixte qui s'appelle
la cmt pour la restauration scolaire
je pense que c'est très intéressant
parce que ça nous permet de générer des
économies et d'être force de proposition
c'est concret on va une dernière
question un peu plus politique forcément
est ce que à terme on pourrait voir
arnaud péricard et karl olive rejoindre
la république en marche concrètement en
2018 je veux dire il ya aucune actualité
il n'y a pas de sujet par rapport à cela
ce la politique d' emmanuel macron
fonctionne marche et efficace vous
parliez d'efficacité de politique qui
marche il y aurait intérêt à essence
finalement à rejoindre ce mouvement moi
je suis tout à fait capable de dire que
le président macron à une excellente
initiative
au lendemain de son élection c'est le
retour la semaine des quatre jours en
matière de réforme scolaire que nous
attendions depuis quatre ans j'applaudis
des deux mains
mais quand je vois par exemple que dans
les yvelines le président bédié va
pouvoir s'appuyer sur les détenteurs du
rsa pour les intégrer en matière
d'emploi et qu'on a quasiment 200 jeunes
qui retrouve de l'emploi par rapport à
ça j'ai produit également dès demain je
pense que hisser au chai exactement je
pense que ici dans les yvelines au
département notamment
il ya beaucoup de choses qui peuvent
être prises en exemple et j'espère que
l'on pourra s'inspirer de cela pour que
demain le futur parti des républicains
dans les yvelines soit d'abord un parti
de pragmatisme avant avant d'être un
parti où chacun vient entre guillemets
ce qu'il reste dans les pattes et c'est
ce qui est inscrit aujourd'hui pour ma
plus d'actualité un karl olive rester
avec nous on passe tout de suite à
l'actualité de la semaine
il
l actualité locale cette semaine marquée
par la visite jeudi d'élise et habite
d'elisabeth bornes excusez-moi la
ministre chargé des transports s'est
rendu sur le site de l'institut vd comme
à versailles la ministre a pu assister à
plusieurs présentations et
démonstrations de véhicules du futur
reportages sur des images de nicolas
d'andré la ministre des transports était
accompagné d'un vice président de la
commission européenne pour découvrir
certains prototypes de l'institut vd
comme que ce soit la voiture électrique
qui se recharge toute seule en roulant
ou cette voiture blanche prototype du
transport à la demande
autonome puis quand la mission a été
acceptée par le poste de commande
centralisé va venir se positionner ici
qui a beaucoup de territoires dans
lequel il faut tout simplement répondre
aux besoins des gens qui n'ont pas le
permis de conduire ou qui n'ont pas la
possibilité de conduire une voiture et
je pense que des solutions de ce type là
demain dans des zones peu denses ça
pourra tout à fait répondre à cet enjeu
de la mobilité pour chacun en pleine
assises nationales de la mobilité cette
visite visait aussi à saluer le travail
de l'institut versailles et vd comme
depuis sa création il ya trois ans
l'institut est devenu un leader européen
dans la recherche de solutions
innovantes pour les transports financée
par des acteurs de l'automobile les
différentes collectivités vd com dispose
aujourd'hui d'un budget annuel de 30
millions d'euros
les axes dans lesquelles on se dirige
sont clairement les axes qui sont
poussés à la fois par la france et par
l'europe c'est des axes de mobilité avec
plusieurs modes en même temps c'est des
axes d'efficience énergétique
c'est aussi des axes dans lequel le
véhicule autonome apporte un vrai plus
sur le transport à la demande pour
poursuivre son développement vd com
prévoit de s'installer l'an prochain
dans de nouveaux locaux à versailles
satory
et la venue de la ministre des
transports à versailles était l occasion
aussi de clarifier pour elle d'autres
actualités et notamment celle de la
ligne 18 qui doit relier à l'horizon
2030 l'aéroport d'orly à versailles dans
le cadre du grand paris express des
rumeurs récentes ont fait part d'un
abandon potentiel du projet par le
gouvernement pour des raisons
économiques et les et bêtes board s'est
voulue rassurante sur le sujet mais sans
évoquer la question du calendrier
écouter il n'est pas question de
remettre en cause les trajets tels
qu'ils ont été discutés dans le cadre du
grand paris comme pour l'ensemble des
infrastructures
on doit réfléchir à une programmation et
à des calendriers mais personne n'a
l'idée de remettre en cause les trajets
le réseau du grand paris tel qu'il a été
arrêté donc la ligne 18 arrivera dans
les yvelines
karl olive j'imagine que c'est un sujet
que vous suivez de près en tant que
qu'élu du conseil départemental
notamment est ce que vous êtes rassurés
par de tels propos puisqu'il y avait
vraiment des rumeurs insistantes 1 cet
été sur un potentiel abandon du projet
là encore c'est une décision de bon sens
et qui effectivement va rassurer pas
seulement le conseil départemental
mais évidemment l'ensemble des habitants
du territoire et ça va dans la droite
ligne de ce que nous mettons en place
dans le nord des yvelines je pense
notamment au rer e et les neuf nouvelles
gares entre mantes la jolie et et poissy
mais également le tramway que nous
allons installer à possible parce que ce
tramway va créer une interconnexion et
on a besoin du soutien de la ministre
bornes par rapport par rapport à cela
puisque ça a été voté à la fois par le
conseil régional par le conseil
départemental avec valérie pécresse et
pierre bédier et qu'aujourd'hui l'état
évidemment est un appui considérable par
rapport à ça il va métamorphoser
véritablement le quotidien de tous nos
habitants
oui c'est une bonne nouvelle est plutôt
rassurante maintenant ce qu'on espère
c'est que ça ne devienne priorités en
termes de calendrier comme j'aimerais
que la ministre puisse couvrir les
dossiers comme le contournement de la
ville de poissy nos territoires comme la
104 vous parliez de calendrier les élus
à l'avs a souhaité même que ce trajet à
versailles à partir de 2024 et pas 2030
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est peine
perdue on va dire déjà six et le trajet
se fait c'est bien alors en 2024 c'est
un peu trop espérer
oui il ne faut pas prendre non plus les
élus pour des naïfs et que
évidemment l'idée c'est encore une fois
de se mettre autour de la table dans les
changes pour montrer et prouver à madame
la ministre board qui a des priorités en
termes de calendrier par rapport à cela
parce que 2030 on est en priorité deux
quasiment et en 2030 c'est parce que
vous ferez moi non plus est est ce qu'on
aura les mêmes les mêmes volonté
aujourd'hui encore une fois la volonté
elle est là de part et d'autre mettons
nous autour de la table et dégageant des
priorités il me semble que c'est le
signal envoyé par le président de la
république alors cette question de
l'alim 18 est évidemment liée à l'avenir
de la métropole du grand paris là aussi
beaucoup de rumeurs des annonces seront
faites fin octobre par emmanuel macron
les informations les plus récentes
laissent penser qu'il y aura un statu
quo sur la géographie de la métropole on
restera sur la petite couronne est donc
la grande couronne qui seraient exclues
de la métropole du grand paris pour vous
c'est c'est pas imaginable ça je pense
surtout qu'il faut encore une fois faire
preuve de pragmatisme et c'est vraiment
le message que nous envoyons aujourd'hui
on travaille le sens de l'histoire c'est
quoi ces mutualiser les biens et les
moyens on travaille sur un rapprochement
sur une fusion entre le département 78
et le département 92 pas pour pas pour
de la flagornerie pour montrer que
lorsqu'on est uni c'est bien plus bien
plus important et puissant je prends le
cas des sociétés d'économie mixte
interdépartemental site alios qui
devient vraiment nous crie une richesse
économique pour permettre à nos
concitoyens avoir des projets que nous
pouvons porter si demain c'est
simplement dénoyauter les compétences et
d'avoir une espèce de grande coquille
vide
ça ne pourra pas fonctionner sanou
rajoutera décroche administrative qui
coûteront de l'argent au contribuable et
à l'état et qui n'empêcheront pas l'état
d'avoir deux mille milliards de 120
millions de dettes et où on est
d'ailleurs sur ce projet de fusion entre
les hauts-de-seine et les et les
yvelines vous attendait l'aval du
gouvernement
qu'en est-il vous discutez avec lui
directement d'abord je rappelle que ce
projet de fusion a été voté à une très
large majorité à la fois au conseil
départemental
du 78 également conseil départemental
des hauts-de-seine cher à patrick
devedjian
aujourd'hui l'état doit se positionner
mais pour nous tous les élus de ces deux
ces deux assiettes on a encore un rendez
vous en début de semaine prochaine pour
pouvoir continuer à poursuivre nos
travaux le musée la lisa science
concrètement je nourris à mais moi j'ai
toujours été d'une nature optimiste donc
je pense qu'il faut être deux farouches
partisans de cette mutualisation c'est
d'abord une mutualisation au sein de
l'intérêt général
maintenant si demain on nous fait la
démonstration camp nou des noyaux temps
en transférant les compétences sans
compensation de la part de l'état c'est
plus efficace
on sera pas de on sera pas de cela et on
se battra pour démontrer à l'actuel
gouvernement et au président la
république que ils font fausse route et
qu'il faut écouter des gens de terre
encore une question vous dit être
optimiste mais aussi réaliste j'imagine
imaginons fin 2017 les yvelines sont en
dehors de la métropole du grand paris et
que le projet de fusion a été refusée
retoqué par le par le gouvernement on se
prépare à de telles éventualités au
concernant partout aujourd'hui on se
prépare pas de telles éventualités pas
seulement d'ailleurs il faut retirer
aussi simplement la singularité du
conseil départemental élevé puisque
l'ensemble des présidents des conseils
départementaux de toute l'ile-de-france
ont fait cause commune
justement pour réclamer la même chose et
dans ces départements dont 100 dans ce
président là encore une fois toutes les
représentations politiques qui sont
présentés donc encore une fois on parle
bien d'un intérêt général et
certainement pas d'addition d'intérêts
particuliers merci karl olive d'être
venu sur notre plateau je rappelle que
vous êtes le maire ait l'air de poissy
vice président du conseil départemental
des yvelines et donc fondateur de la
nouvelle association génération terrain
merci voilà un nouveau visage à la tête
de l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'information
a été officialisée jeudi après-midi le
professeur alain buey a été élu par le
conseil d'administration de
l'établissement vous voyez son visage
s'afficher à l'écran il remplace le
professeur didier guillemot qui a remis
sa démission en septembre pour des
raisons de santé son mandat court
jusqu'en mai 2000 20 jeudi également 77
personnes ont été évacuées sur
différents campements situés à saint
quentin en yvelines plusieurs familles
ont ainsi dû quitter leur installation
sur trappe et montigny
le bretonneux elles ont été ensuite
redirigés vers des chambres d'hôtel
d'hébergement en ile de france un
déplacement en dehors des yvelines faute
de place qui inquiète justement les
quelques membres des associations
locales qui étaient présentes sur place
écoutez il ya un jeune dont je sais très
bien qu'il a c'est un cdi donc là on l'a
empêché d'aller au boulot
j'espère qu'il va pas perdre son boulot
il y en a deux autres qui ont eu du mal
à trouver un travail qui depuis huit
jours en ont un
donc là aussi sont téléphoné en disant
on peut pas venir travailler mais voilà
ils vont être envoyées le ce qu'il faut
faire c'est ouvrir plus de places
d'hébergement dans le coin
pour justement les héberger et là où ils
ont une vie parce qu'ils ont vraiment
une vie ici à guyancourt toujours la
croix rouge a officiellement inauguré
son nouvel espace dédié aux parents et
aux bébés cette semaine dans le quartier
est des garennes vous voyez les images
celui ci doit notamment répondre aux
difficultés économiques et sociales que
peuvent rencontrer certaines familles
avec par exemple des ateliers conseils
pour les mamans ou encore la
distribution de nourriture et raie manta
sion qui a été lancé au mois de juin à
magny les hameaux les élèves de l'école
élémentaire louise weiss et riz
désormais leur plateau à la cantine
objectif les sensibiliser pour lutter
contre le gaspillage alimentaire un
projet fruit du partenariat entre la
commune des associations et le parc
naturel régional de la haute vallée de
chevreuse et mélanie poké et michael et
demi d'euros dresser un premier bilan de
l'opération eco responsable alors que le
28 mètres dans le compost dans la
poubelle à compost est ce que tu sais ce
que tu peux lire
les réflexes ne sont pas encore naturel
pour cette élève de l'école louise weiss
depuis le début du mois de juin les
écoliers triste qu'ils restent dans leur
script savait dès la nature j'adore la
nature à j'ai fait très attention
je sais qu'il sera d'ailleurs pour les
déchets bah ça leur permet de faire
moins de travail l'école élémentaire est
la première des neuf établissements de
la commune a testé cette expérience une
sensibilisation qui se fait avec les
élèves les enseignants des associations
manic oise et les services municipaux
c'est en fait la plus grosse école de la
commune
elle confie qu'elle comprend onze
classes et à la restauration scolaire il
ya 245 élèves donc et un comptage a été
fait et en moyenne ya quinze kilos de
déchets par jour
ces actions comme beaucoup d'autres
d'ailleurs que l'on mène dans notre
école s'inscrivent dans notre projet
d'école dans ce projet d'école il est
prévu un volet agenda 21
et donc nous sommes amenés en place et
avec des enfants
à
les sensibiliser sur tous les enjeux
écologiques les enjeux de protection de
la planète et protection de
l'environnement est également sur le
développement durable
les restes sont ensuite jetés dans des
composteurs installé dans la cour en
début de semaine un compost qui sera
utilisé pour les espaces verts de la
ville
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'aide au
retour de l'information en direct à
lundi 18h sur tv les 78 d'ici là restez
informés et collecté grâce à notre site
internet et nos applications tv 78 bon
week-end à tous et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]